China this morning state-run media say
Beijing will win any trade war with with
the US China announced tariffs this week
targeting industries like pork beef and
soybeans that are important in
republican-leaning States Dean Reynolds
is at a pig farm in Tipton Indiana one
of the many that could be hurt if
there's a trade war Dean good morning
good morning well last year the u.s.
exported some 1.1 billion dollars worth
of pork to China and the pork industry
supports about five hundred and fifty
thousand jobs in mostly rural America
which overwhelmingly supported Donald
Trump I don't think there's any segment
of our industry that will escape some
financial hard times if we do indeed see
a diminished export market
Keith shut Murr is a pig farmer and
Trump supporter the thought of a
possible 25% Chinese tariff on American
pork makes him nervous if you had the
president right here what would you tell
him we would just reiterate just how
vitally important the exports are to our
industry China's tariffs would impact
nearly ten percent of all US pork
exports of the top ten pork producing
states in the US eight of them voted for
president Trump in 2016 are you
reconsidering your support for him we
have to have a a trust that he has our
best interest in mind and we just have
to believe that there's more to these
negotiations that we understand
China's proposed 25% tariff on American
Soybean could have an even bigger
financial impact on US farmers the
American Soybean Association says China
buys nearly 1/3 of US production
annually that includes about a quarter
of all the soybeans grown in Illinois
I'm not as enthusiastic as supporter as
I was two years ago Trump supporter
Eldon Gould is one of Illinois over
43,000 soybean farmers well I I guess I
would have to say that I'm disappointed
and I'll be the first admit that I voted
for mr. Trump but I was hoping that he
would take a more reasonable approach to
trade now yesterday the White House
economic adviser Larry Kudlow suggested
that all this talk about tariffs may
just be a negotiating ploy and the White
House in fact said the door is open for
further talks with Beijing and that no
firm date has been set for the
imposition of US tariffs against China
so Norah the talk of tariffs may just be
threats but still can affect real people
as you point out Dean thank you so much